cours de formation géographiques et
sociales cinquième année aujourd'hui
l'état à la base de cet exposé le
dictionnaire de géographie des éditions
hatier les termes états nations et pays
utilisent largement géographie cette
discipline étudie notamment les
relations de l'état à son territoire
mais cherche aussi à comprendre la
montée des nationalismes les relations
entre états voir les conséquences pour
les états de la supranationalité
croissante en matière d'économie
l'état et la nation sont les notions de
base l'état est une réalité objective
puisqu'elle est consacré par le droit
elle existe dans les règlements
internationaux et dans les législations
nationales et la nation qui est une
réalité plutôt subjectif puisque la
nation non le verrons plus tard c'est un
petit peu la consécration d'un sentiment
d'appartenance à une unité à une
communauté commune de la part des
individus
intéressons nous tout d'abord à au
concept d'état l'état c'est l'autorité
souveraine qui s'exerce sur un
territoire un territoire national alors
le premier élément de cette définition
c'est l'autorité souveraine
qu'est ce que c'est mais une autorité
souveraine c'est une puissance qui ne
reçoit d'ordres de personne qui est la
source ultime du pouvoir la belgique n'a
d'ordre à recevoir en tant qu'etat de
personnes c'est ça la souveraine
la julienne territoire sur lequel cette
autorité s'exerce ce territoire est
lui-même défini par des frontières
communément reconnues c'est ce que nous
avons vu dans des vidéos précédent on a
donc la face visible de l'état bien sûr
ce sont l'administration et le
gouvernement
l'état belge va être présentée par le
premier ministre et par son
administration
l'ensemble des fonctionnaires qui
travaillent pour cet état
taille donc un phénomène juridique
puisqu'il est définie par la loi c'est
la constitution et l'ensemble des
règlements nationaux mais aussi
internationaux qui permettent à la
belgique par exemple d'exister le
territoire est lui-même défini par la
loi et par le droit international
l'état n'existe que s'il est reconnu par
les autres comme légitime
certains états des clercs parfois leur
indépendance mais ne sont pas reconnus
internationalement et donc ne sont pas
de véritables états donc à la fois il ya
une définition qui vient de l'état
lui-même mais aussi de l'extérieur
le concept de souveraineté évidemment
qui est lié à celui de la démocratie et
du peuple qui est la source de cette
souveraineté
le peuple belge à un certain moment va
déléguer sa souveraineté au représentant
de l'état c'est à dire aux politiques et
aux vins de l'état a trois fonctions
une fonction normative faire des
règlements faire la loi
une fonction exécutive mettre ses lois
en application et faire en sorte que
tout fonctionne et une fonction
judiciaire qui est simplement de régler
les conflits qui peuvent exister autour
de ces règles qui ont été édictées un
certain mamba si on n'est pas d'accord
un juge va trancher pour vous en se
basant sur les règlements qui sont en
vigueur
évidemment un état à plusieurs missions
notamment la sécurité de ses citoyens
aussi l'enseignement qui est une des
principales missions et je ne dis pas ça
en tant qu'enseignant mais c'est parce
qu'au niveau des dépenses publiques
l'enseignement fait partie des priorités
des états il y à bien d'autres fonctions
comme bien sûr la garantie de liberté
la mise en place de certaines
infrastructures la cohésion sociale et
bien d'autres choses encore lorsque l'on
s'intéresse à la géographie des conflits
on ne peut pas faire abstraction de ce
concept anglo saxon de fight stay fights
tête sont les états faillis les états en
faillite les états en déliquescence
en fait des états qui n'arrive plus
pour diverses raisons ça peut être la
corruption ou alors le manque de
ressources économiques les états qui
n'arrivent plus à assumer leur autorité
qui n'arrivent plus à assurer leur
mission et qui n'arrivent plus à
garantir le respect des règles de droit
ni la sécurité des citoyens
nous remarquerons que souvent les
conflits émane de situation où il y a
des états faillis en actions pour
pouvoir définir clairement qu'ils sont
quels sont les états faillis on va
utiliser toute une série d'indicateurs
ici vous avez des indicateurs sociaux
économiques et politiques
ça pourra faire écho évidemment à votre
grille d'analysé
une fois que tous ces indicateurs sont
croisés on peut établir vraiment une
carte cartographie de ces états faillis
vous voyez que principalement ils sont
situés en afrique mais qu' on retrouve
bien sûr cet arc des conflits cet arc
des crises dont nous avons déjà parlé
qui subvient se superposer sur cette
géographie des états faillis d'autre
part nous avons un autre concept en
marge de celui des tasses et qui est
celui de nation la nation en fait c'est
une construction identitaire partagé par
une communauté d'hommes marquée par un
sentiment d'appartenance à une culture
commune ayant ou revendiquant un
territoire spécifique
vous vous sentez sans doute belge
peut-être wallon voir membres de la
bolivie carte bruxelles doit je ne sais
pas quel est votre d'identité mais voilà
ce qu'est une nation c'est un ensemble
cohérent d'individus qui ont le même
sentiment d'appartenance une ethnie on
emploie souvent ce terme en jeu harry
aussi c'est un terme plus restrictif là
ça va être une population qui est encore
plus cohérente parce qu'elle possède des
caractéristiques vraiment commune la
langue la religion la culture tandis
qu'au niveau de la nation on pourra
avoir des individus qui ont une langue
ferrante mais qui se déclarent être de
la même nation la france est une nation
de ce type
puisque on va voir par exemple les
bretons les bretons ne veulent pas
forcément sortir de la france mais tout
en ayant leur culture propre
mais ce sens de membre à part entière de
la nation française alors maintenant que
les deux termes ont été définis on peut
les combinés on peut combiner l'état
nation pour obtenir tout simplement
l'état nation l'état nation c'est cette
forme juridique qui est l'état qui vient
se superposer à une communauté d'hommes
qui veulent vivre ensemble
alors ici on a bien le regroupement de
deux réalités différentes une ré était
clairement objective une réalité plus
subjectif puisque vécue par les
individus quelques exemples pour
illustrer ce qui vient d'être dit on va
retrouver dans le monde des nations sans
état
si vous avez un article de l'arc tdf qui
fait part de la nation qu laclos nation
cure de pardon la plus grande nation
sans état du monde on pourrait avoir le
cas de figure inverse où par exemple le
royaume uni est un état avec quatre
nations différentes qui d'ailleurs où
chacune leur drapeau chacune leur
histoire et chacune par exemple et qui
peut représenter hâtives au niveau de
différents sports au pays diala
l'angleterre l'écossé et l'irlande du
nord
la belgique est une est un état avec une
nation la nation flamande qui a
clairement une identité commune et une
volonté commune est une nation belge
finalement puisque les wallons eux ne se
sentent pas forcément liés entre eux en
tant que nation wallonne donc là la
belgique est vraiment un cas de figure
très intéressant à étudier avec ces
concepts
la france est un état nation presque
abouti puisque bien qu'il y ait des
ethnies et des cultures fort différentes
ces ensembles techniques veulent se
mettre ensemble pour former cette nation
française à quelques exceptions
et puisque nous aurons par exemple de
forts mouvements nationalistes corses ou
basque dans le sud est et le sud ouest
de la france
cet exposé est maintenant finie je vous
propose comme de coutume de passer au
quiz
si vous avez d'éventuelles questions
n'hésitez pas à les noter pour vous en
rappeler en classe et déposer au groupe
je vous remercie de votre attention et à
très bientôt